all right we have a trailer for Ralph
breaks the internet which is in fact
wreck-it Ralph - and this is my trailer
review on it which actually isn't a
review I just call it a review this is
essentially my thoughts on what I see
and what I might want to see in the
movie
it starts out Ralph goes to Fenella
pains like we're going to the Internet
and they both get pumped into place that
Daft Punk song that will perpetually
make me think of River City ransom it
looks like it's gonna have a lot of
jokes that the emoji movie tried to have
or at least tried to pull off first dude
that go-to is trying to do autocorrect
so he's trying to finish their sentences
finish their words well that was pretty
clever
she tells him to take them to a website
that's super intense and really nuts so
they essentially go to what looks like
Disneyland visible in California
Adventure looks like the same point as
Disney makes this movie so Disney's
gonna show us the things they own
flexing a little bit sure but could make
for a lot of fun cuz Disney owns a lot
of stuff Ironman flies by let me see TIE
fighters he's Star Wars land but really
if she's looking for something that's
intense and really nuts she needs to
find the websites that are talking about
Star Wars movies right now not
necessarily Star Wars itself yeah and
this movie they can go to Star Wars land
go to the YouTube section of Star Wars
land and find people talking [ __ ] about
solo and find people talking [ __ ] about
the people talking [ __ ] about solo have
fun but the interesting thing I noticed
in this trailer is that there are no
videogame property which is the thing I
loved about wreck-it Ralph which is the
thing I was looking forward to in
wreck-it Ralph - I mean the first
trailer I saw freckie Roth was like what
it was like a videogame Wonderland of
official videogame characters and
properties and unofficial video game
characters and properties they're still
represented what we knew they
represented point is for the most part
it was the only movie that we would see
these video game characters in that was
actually a good movie it was a movie
that was a love letter to video games so
for wreck-it Ralph - I was looking
forward to seeing more properties that
were like hey here yeah use ours instead
it looks like Disney's like da we'll use
ours it's more affordable for us that's
not to say there are going to be no
video game properties in this movie and
the first record Ralph they went to
multiple worlds this might just be the
first of many worlds they go to I'm just
saying I would like to see video game
characters in this movie video game
characters interacting with these movie
characters that would actually be quite
amazing I hope that go that route I mean
it being Roth breaks the internet let's
face it Internet's a huge part of our
lives most of our social interaction
comes from it which are lots opportunity
to show what the interaction actually
looks like like you can have someone
just talking about something there's one
person hears it and it gets out a
megaphone that says retweet on it I was
like the world today and a whole mob
comes over and starts beating that first
dudes ass we had the
in the first place gonna have gas
zombie-like that's what that interaction
would look like that's no conversation
people don't have conversations online
they have yelling matches and that's
that so that does afford an opportunity
to illustrate that absurdity I'd
actually find that quite interesting to
just get the end of that was pretty
funny when it's a roomful of princesses
and they're all looking at her and
they're like are you a princess have you
been kidnapped have you been poisoned
they go down the laundry list of things
they have been through she's like are
you all okay do I need to call the
police Cinderella breaks her glass
slipper and uses it as a broken bottle
knife though nice pretty model I'm
looking forward to it I just hope it's
not Ralph Rex Disneyland that's not what
made the first record Ralph's great it
was a video game properties he's a video
game character that in the fact that it
was a very enjoyable adventure with good
character and if you're gonna
essentially have him go into movie land
on the Internet I would like to see the
video game world in the movie world
collide even make a joke about being a
princess because everyone assumes your
problems are solved because big strong
man comes and saves a day I feel like
the greatest value you could add to that
is have Bowser and Peach in this movie
somehow because that is are always
kidnap speech let's see what happens
honestly it's fingers crossed here's
hoping the sequel is as good as the
first one right so the trailer for Ralph
breaks the internet wreck-it Ralph -
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
[Music]